okay so around lunchtime we just
finished the morning seed that we
providing just taking a walk around the
camps and all of a sudden I felt very
dizzy and I thought oh I'm going to pass
out and I just happened to be on the
phone to Rebbe at the time I said I
think the heat affected me when I looked
then all of a sudden I looked up and I
saw children that had been playing
happily screaming screaming absolutely
petrified just chaos all around and very
very scared I've never seen anybody so
scared in my life you know these people
they were just confused and then I look
towards my team members further further
away from me and they said quick get
here and all I can recall is that I was
trying to run to try and get to them
quickly but I wasn't going anywhere it
was very bizarre but the ground just it
waves it was just moving it was a very
bizarre but you know quickly we realized
that we had to keep a cool head because
these people were traumatized in their
suffering so quickly these sort of
regained our composure and thought right
we're the ones that are fresh in this we
have to show the leadership and you know
let them started reassuring people but
it was very scary very scary indeed and
so rather you were on the phone to bow
when they'll happen so it must have been
terrifying for you as well just to see
how going through that yeah first I
thought it might be a tremor I said oh
it could be a tremor and then she kept
saying no nice going on and on sort of
thing and I think it's the first time a
bee bells been in that situation with
you actual full-on earthquake and I
could hear a thing the kids are scared
she doesn't what's going on
spit surreal and and I said look see
flower teams okay the volunteers because
they were helping out in the feed and
then we got disconnected and we got on
the phone trying to find exactly what
happened and it turned out to be quite
big earthquake and alarm bells start
ringing and so you know it's quite scary
well yes and Belle explain to us how
your day panned out there give us a
sense of what the situation is like now
there in Katmandu they're very
challenging days and so once once the
earthquake sister down a bit people
along the home on the main town the city
that we're in everybody just abandoned
there
vehicles and they flooded into the
military base where we are it's a very
open area flatlands so all of a sudden
people were just flooding in and just
where we are under our marquee where we
do the cooking we have about 500 people
that sought refuge there and just all
along the sides of the flatlands
basically everybody just just made their
way there to feel safe and and you know
people people so traumatized people
crying and there were only a handful of
us in comparison but we tried to give
them water a bit of reassurance and say
look you're safe you know you're on flat
ground you'll be safe and the people
hesitant to go back to normal life they
sat there for a couple of hours we
provided tea and we try to sort of
create a sense of normality which is
very challenging as you can imagine but
then you know as people so they were
reluctant to get back out out of that
space because it's an open space and
just just as an estimate of how many
people may be affected this time around
we usually cater for about 2,500 people
at lunchtime and in the evening this
evening we've provided meals to 8,000
people so we will see tomorrow how many
of those are displaced people or how
many just simply sought shelter today in
that area and very challenging day very
scary and generally people are sleeping
on the streets now they're scared to go
into a building
yeah hugely traumatic for everybody
there Rafi and of course you've just
returned yourself and tell us what your
thoughts are given the scenes that you
saw just a few days ago uh when I landed
there about ten days ago a few days
after the earthquake people are sleeping
outside they were too scared to go in
and as a time progressed my time there
people started going back into the
buildings and now this is throwing them
back out again and the problem will not
be sleeping tonight Nepal is obviously
thinking a lot of people who ve anxious
they'll be on the streets they'll
probably without shelter as well and in
the rural areas one of our trustees he's
a pilot as well and he volunteered to go
he was delivering aid into the
mountainous region in the villages and
he's come back very very moved and very
traumatizing the way because he actually
saw the buildings
and he said we're lucky we made it alive
there's a lot of things in this
situation where like I visited villages
or how was that and there's one
particular guy that flashed the family
flashed in my mind again and again this
morning that was a family that we looked
up half the house had gone in the first
earthquake it was about to fall and we
were saying to them please please come
down we will give you shelter we
guarantee shelter it wouldn't be moved
there's about six or eight people in the
building
grandma granddad and the whole family
and this morning you know I know the
worst of it probably happen because they
would have just gone over and I hope
they know you know fidelity so there's a
lot of stuff a lot of kids are cool
annoyed they won't even go in the shower
or the boss you know they're so scared
they might happen again now this will
set it back again people are gonna be
out if we're going to be scared it will
be anxious so the feeding program would
be for two and a half thousand normally
that's going to double because of people
are gonna be staying in the flat ground
so but we're catering for it we offer
our volunteers are out there so it is a
very traumatic time for people involved
is I've never seen such a massive to go
hit such a short time and well your
husband explains it so it's like so well
there but there's not just people's
physical needs it's also the mental
support the people need as well the
psychological support
toom how well-placed do you feel you are
there and other aid agencies in
providing the help that's needed I think
at the moment that's generally people
are struggling to come to terms with
what's happened and be that aid agencies
or it's very challenging to deliberate
never mind the psychological aspects of
it children are very traumatized and I
think today's being them panic you know
and my turn today
that just hit home how much their former
ties and when you speak to some of the
children they you know they they're
established families they've got they
had a good home they come from doing
well at school all that's gone overnight
and you listen to some of these children
tell their stories of how they've ended
up at these camps it's very upsetting
this traumatising what